you get to spend most of your time on
this movie working with jim carrey which
is
amazing so i am curious what does it
cost to be in the movie to work with jim
carrey do you is it like five bucks 20
bucks like what did you pay paramount to
be in the film that's a very good
question i uh i basically signed off i
think my entire estate
um and uh in exchange they were like
cool you get to work with jim carrey um
but uh but we can tell you when that
stops
so i'm just hoping i'm just hoping they
keep uh they keep uh bringing me back
i signed off a lot man i signed away a
lot
uh but seriously all kidding aside i
love jim i know you must love everyone
loves jim i love that what does it
actually like working with him because
he is so good in this role but he's
always so good you know
you know i get asked this question so
much and i don't think i've ever been
able to really put
it into words you know it's like
growing up with jim and and him being
someone i looked up to as a kid and and
watching ace ventura in the mask and
eventually eternal sunshine of the
spotless mind and like
i don't think he's ever done anything
bad
um
and then to work with him and see how
wonderful he is and how dedicated he is
and how specific he is and how gracious
and and big-hearted
um i don't think
i could have asked for
uh
a better experience
uh with the sequel it's like bigger
better like you know it's huge action
set pieces what are you most excited for
audiences to see
oh there's so much there's so much great
stuff in this movie it's it's it's so
much bigger
i think there's so many incredible nods
to the video games i think video game
fans will be
will be incredibly happy
um
[Music]
i love i love the interaction between uh
knuckles tails sonic and robotnik like
just seeing the four of them on screen
together
is so cool
one of the other things is that uh uh
you get to do scenes with uh you know
not like you know there's the knuckles
the doctor stuff um what is it like
actually on set filming something like
that is it like a little weird to be
talking essentially to like a tennis
ball or whatever it might be
you know not as weird as you'd think i
mean maybe i'm just crazy i don't know
um but you know i got i got into acting
because
you know i wanted to
express myself i always was you know a
pretty energetic kid i loved using my
imagination and so i think you know you
just you just buy into what you're doing
you buy into who you're talking to
um and it doesn't end up being that hard
everybody's there doing the same thing
you know they all like want it to work
so it makes it so much easier to do it i
love learning about the the behind the
scenes the making of film um what do you
think maybe like would surprise fans to
learn about the actual making of the
movie
oh wow that's a good question
uh
how much how much work goes into making
a movie there's so many people that you
never
you never see on screen
who have
so much
invested in in making a movie
the crew uh the amount of details that
go into
i don't know like
planning and and and wardrobe and uh
lighting and all of that i think it's
just it's massive massive on that note
oh sorry yeah go now go ahead oh and i
was going to say on that note i will
talk your ear off steve
listen
he's going to be a huge hit i want to
say congrats on being a part of it and i
wish you nothing but the best
i appreciate it thank you so much